c'est le parti communiste français en
campagne à la verrière distribution de
tracts pour les élections européennes
échanges avec les habitants du bois de
l'étang la maire de la ville nelly duthu
accompagné de l'ancien secrétaire
national du pcf pierre laurent
j'ai besoin d'aller sur le terrain
comprendre ce que c'est que les
difficultés et les projets aussi d'une
d'une commune comme celle là une commune
où il ya beaucoup de logements sociaux
on a des ambitions de développement
culturel social pour cette ville
il faut en avoir les moyens les
questions européennes semblent loin des
préoccupations du quartier les habitants
s'intéresse plutôt aux thématiques
locales notamment le projet de
rénovation du bois de l'étang
nous on est contre une démolition c'est
un projet qui a été initié par monsieur
hajjaj l'ancien maire qui a demandé des
démissions alors qu'il n'avait pas
besoin de faire des démolitions
nous on demande une rénovation du voile
et en ont une ou en irrigation du centre
commercial est en relation des logements
intérieur le problème c'est qu'on veut
reconstruire mais ce sera quoi déjà ce
sera pas du hlm donc ça veut dire que la
plupart des gens qui vivent ici ne
pourront pas accéder à cette invitation
puisque ce seront des habitations à la
vente on n'a pas les moyens d'y accéder
un sujet source d'incertitude sur
l'avenir des bâtiments depuis plusieurs
années
rénovation sans ou avec démolition la
question n'est pas tranchée la ville va
organiser des réunions avec les
habitants soit on tombe sur un projet
comment et tant mieux soit on tombe sur
deux projets et ces deux projets seront
mis au vote les citoyens du quartier
ma position c'est je défends le projet
qui est majoritaire sur le quartier un
premier projet de rénovation du quartier
du bois de l'étang doit être rendu avant
la fin de l'année